welcome back downtown is rocking again
with free concerts
every saturday night and this weekend
they're going back to the 90s
with sister hazel and tonic earlier i
spoke with ryan newell from sister hazel
about the show
ryan welcome to the show buddy how you
doing doing great how are you
fantastic we're excited to have you and
tonic we're talking sister hazel
and tonic in concert july 31st downtown
is this going to be your first concert
in front of fans
no we've we've been playing uh
we actually did drive-in shows uh
summer of 2020. uh those are interesting
uh and then we just started about two or
three months ago getting back in
in actual rooms with people you're the
guitarist for
for sister hazel you have some guitars
behind you i i got a bowl behind me
oh yeah any special guitars you have
they were like what's the one behind you
right there
uh this is a this is gibson les paul
uh over here that's actually a brian may
from queen signature guitar and that one
over there that's a gretch guitar
let's go back to the beginning because
the band sister hazel you guys
form you start in 1993 and then all for
you
becomes a smash hit all over the radio
all over the country
in 1997 so we're talking 40 years here
what was that initial ride like for you
guys well
i mean we were in a van and trailer at
the time we're doing it all on our own
no label support we recorded our
first uh it was a cassette tape
at basically as a demo to get gigs we
knew the song did well
live and we felt confident that if
someone would just give it a chance it
would do well and
you know it started get you know the
phone started ringing off the hook
people wondering who it was and they're
getting requests for this song
and then that's when the major labels
started calling the radio stations
saying
who is this band you know that it
has no label support no nothing
and they're you know getting all these
requests and all this air time on your
station
and then that kind of started a bidding
war we ended up going with universal
records i believe it was
number one on four formats at the same
time
um and it didn't go away um i think it's
been 11 weeks on the charts
it's crazy you know we went from a
vantage trailer to getting a tour bus
and showing up in in weird towns and
seeing a line around the building and
you know it blew our minds it still
blows our minds that people come and see
us play
[Music]
now who we are old friends with uh that
lives out in vegas is carrot top but we
sent him a text saying that we were
going to be there
and he was like hell yeah let's do it
like no logistics no like well we'll
call you
just like let's do it sister hazel and
tonic are in concert this saturday night
on fremont street it is a free show
las vegas now will be right